hey youtubers is Charlie and hopefully
you guys have all had a chance to see
some of my comic-con panels that I've
posted I tried to get as many as
possible especially some of the ones
that you guys really requested so now I
know you all want to talk about all the
trailers so I asked you on Twitter which
one you wanted to see first and Avengers
one of course I kind of expected that
because there are so many others to do I
will explain at the end of this video
which other ones I'm gonna be doing this
week and I'll announce who won my Marvel
giveaway hello any new people if you're
just finding me for the first time or
you found me during all my comic-con
stuff welcome I do Marvel videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even gonna be doing a whole bunch of
guardians videos this week just because
the movies out in theaters they even
announced guardians to at Marvel but I'm
gonna talk about that in a separate
video let's talk about that WTF Avengers
2 trailer in case you didn't see it I
did a video a couple weeks ago that
ended up being pretty close to the
footage they showed off at Comic Con of
course the actual trailer they showed
off had a bunch of new footage that no
one else had seen before I know a bunch
of you guys have asked me and no I can't
post the actual footage from the trailer
it's super illegal Disney would throw me
into a deep dark black hole in the
ground they were actually a bunch of
people that leaked Deadpool footage as
well as the Batman vs Superman clip Fox
Marvel Warner Brothers they're all gonna
sue them into oblivion
on the other hand though Marvel was
really nice and posted a whole bunch of
pictures of the props and
behind-the-scenes stuff so I will use
those when I'm talking about the footage
so careful for spoilers if you don't
want to know anything about Avengers age
of Ultron I talked about this in
previous videos before but you could
consider it kind of spoilery because
most of you will not be able to see this
trailer for the next eight months so
I'll wait just a second okay here we go
first there was the party scene that
I've talked about before it's in a fully
operational Avengers Tower it's sick how
awesome it looks if you remember at the
end of the first Avengers movie Tony
Stark and Pepper Potts were looking at
blueprints all the avengers including
Thor are living on earth full time in
this movie or have been guardians of the
galaxy happens about 6 months earlier in
the timeline but they have not
interacted with the Avengers yet I
repeat yet they will eventually so it's
been happening since Winter Soldier is
the Avengers have been going around the
world cleaning up these remaining Hydra
cells like the labs that Baron von
Strucker was in at the end of Winter
Soldier with Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch
remember he also had Lucky's staff in
that bunker
- because Hydra was so embedded in the
organization's of the world that
day-to-day grind of cleaning up all
these remnants has gotten too exhausting
and to maximize efficiency Tony Stark
creates Ultron
he's like an 8 foot tall robot that
looks like he's been built out of other
Iron Man suits but he has a new AI that
Tony develops based on Jarvis that has
the ability to learn
you know like Terminator Skynet style
Ultron's mission parameters as defined
by Tony Stark are to eradicate evil and
make the world a better place
cue the scary music because of the way
robots think with the cold efficiency of
a machine and because of the loose
language and operating parameters that
Tony Stark inputs Ultron ultimately
determines that humans are the problem
and in order to make the world a better
place they need to be eliminated thus
Ultron begins his war against the
Avengers armed with his own army of
Ultron replicants so in the Avengers
tower during this big party scene it
just starts with them laughing and
having fun chilling out taking turns
trying to pick up Thor's hammer Thor
obviously says you are all unworthy
even though Captain America is kind of
able to make it budge everyone in Hall H
went freakin crazy whenever that
happened in the comics Captain America's
actually used Thor's hammer a couple
times but he's never done it on screens
so you guys will totally go nuts
whenever you see it in theaters so then
there's a big noise everyone turns and
it's Ultron he's busting their party and
he says there is one path to peace your
extinction and then he just opens fire
on them then it cut to a montage of WTF
action scenes with explosions all over
the world Bruce Banner in the woods
tanks fighting in the snow all over the
place like literally all over the world
then it cuts to another scene where Tony
Stark has this line he says this is the
end the end of the path that I put us on
and Black Widow says nothing lasts
forever
then it cuts to a different scene Tony
Stark is fighting Hulk in his Hulkbuster
armor this is the concept art but here's
a look at the actual prop replica of the
arm is freaking awesome right then it
cuts to another scene of Ultron saying
look no strings on me with a little bit
of wit obviously you have to picture
James Spader's creepy robot voice coming
out of his face picture one of his
speeches from the blacklist only process
to sound more like a machine voice like
Jarvis so then it ends on a scene with
Tony Stark looking over this like debris
strewn battlefield with all the Avengers
just hadn't the kicked out of them
even Captain America
shield has been cracked this is actually
what the prop looks like in real life so
this is what its gonna look like in the
movie and it's basically the scene that
happens after this promo image you know
the big one that all the posters combine
to make over the past weekend that they
released they basically went up against
Ultron in a big army of his replicants
got their asses handed to them Andy
Serkis did appear briefly in the
background of a battle scene it was
super quick but it was live action
meaning that it wasn't a mocap creature
and he was most definitely evil-looking
so whenever you're Theory crafting about
who he might be playing just think of
you know human people in the Marvel
Universe villains that are real people I
don't think it's gonna be MODOK or
anything I'm still thinking of MODOK as
like a Patton Oswalt joke just that
Patton Oswalt whenever he heard he was
gonna be on agents of shield thought
that he might be playing MODOK just
because the way he looks but that's
pretty much it so you've seen what
Ultron looks like in his final form but
we're actually gonna see the evolution
of his you know upgrades throughout the
course of the movie this poster that
they released the really cool-looking
one is not what he looks like when Tony
Stark first builds him before he turns
on them he looks more like an Iron Man
suit one of the first things that Joss
Whedon said about Ultron is is that as
he learns more he will continue to
upgrade himself until he looks like he
does in that poster if you guys watch
the panel footage I uploaded whenever
Josh Brolin came out with the Infinity
Gauntlet it actually made me think what
if Fano steps in to help for a price
like bargaining the tesseract for his
assistance of course it's gonna be
vision to take ultron on directly he's
like the good son of Tony Stark they've
kind of explained it as like a good son
bad son situation think of Avengers 2 is
like a story about two brothers Ultron
and vision like Cain and Abel in the
biblical sense except the ending is a
little bit different ultimately I still
think the Marvel panel was one of the
best ones at comic-con people were a
little disappointed just because they
have six mystery films they didn't talk
about any of them they basically just
talked about all the films in 2015
ant-man
and age of Ultron and I think there are
a couple practical reasons why they did
that the biggest being that they have a
ton of unsigned deals with actors
writers and directors for all those
films so until all those people have
signed ink on paper the dates for all
those respective movies where they want
to put them could totally change think
about all the stuff that's been going on
with ant-man so they've lost a ton of
people a bunch of actors just bailed out
of the movie they don't have a finished
script and they
shooting in a couple weeks so that just
gives you an idea of how far behind
Marvel is right now so they have all
these other films but people have just
not signed their deals yet the other big
reason why I don't think they t's big
phase 3 stuff is the guardians of the
galaxy it's being released this week and
if they talk too much about other big
films it would place still a little bit
of thunder from it they just want to
spend more time promoting a movie that's
coming out in a week rather than one
that's coming out in like four years
it's actually didn't confirm anything
but they did drop guardians to that's
being released July 28th 2017 James Gunn
had already said he was gonna direct it
if the first ones did well enough and
based on projections and early ticket
sales it totally will so yeah Marvel
panel was good not quite as good as the
Tom Hiddleston panel from last year but
Batman and Superman I would say is like
a close second it was pretty cool to see
the Holy Trinity up on stage even if
they didn't talk or do anything ant-man
was a little bit weird with Michael
Douglas old mansplaining the plot of the
movie given that we're all comic book
nerds and we've read ant-man before but
what do you expect he's Michael Douglas
but I will be doing a whole bunch of
guardians videos just because that
movies coming out be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'll be doing some guardians to videos
too just with stories I think they
should do obviously we want them to
bring Nova into the story it's like the
next big step for their franchise as
well as deepening the fan oohs mythology
in preparation for Avengers 3 so in case
you didn't see I started a whole bunch
of videos last week for like Marvel
Flash all the big things that I do on my
channel that were at Comic Con so I'll
be announcing the winners for each of
those whenever I post those trailer
videos the winner of my Marvel giveaway
is Amy Hales so congrats you win a
marvel of Funko pop figure of your
choice I'll be messaging you on your
channel for details but congratulations
so I have like eight or ten other
giveaways so if you do end up winning
one of the giveaways and you don't see a
message for me just message me on
Twitter there's a link for that in the
description I'm trying to keep it all
straight just there's just so much stuff
to get through this week so my next big
trailer break down as you guys requested
is going to be the arrow season 3
trailer with Rachel Ghul you can click
here to get that a lot of the intentions
as soon as I post it and you can click
here to watch the full Marvel panel if
you haven't watched it you should
totally check it out it's amazing thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives
you